la deuxième attaque de drone en moins
d'un mois sur la base russe de Sarah tof
une base située à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres de la ligne de froid en
Ukraine une information du ministère
russe de la Défense qui déplore la mort
de trois employés de l'armée tu es par
des débris d'un drone intercepté par la
défense aérienne russe hier dans un
entretien Vladimir Poutine réaffirmé
être prêt à négocier pour obtenir des
résultats dit-il acceptables et sortir
du conflit mais vous allez l'entendre le
président zenki lui n'y crois pas il dit
s'attendre à une fin d'année sombre et
difficile
il ne reste que quelques jours avant la
fin de l'année
nous devons être conscients que notre
ennemi va essayer de rendre ce moment
sombre et difficile
la Russie a perdu tout ce qu'elle
pouvait perdre cette année mais elle
essaie de compenser ses pertes en se
vantant et en faisant de la propagande
après les attaques de Rocket sur notre
pays et nous infrastructures
énergétiques
[Musique]